So, how do we forget? One reason we forget things is because of interference.
Interference is a disruption of memory because of new information that competes
with information we are trying to recall. Now, there are two types of
interference. One is called retroactive interference. With retroactive
interference new experiences or information cause people to forget what they've
previously learned or experienced. The second type of interference is proactive
interference. Proactive interference occurs when previously learned information
interferes with the learning of new information. Let's look at an example of an
retroactive interference. First is a learning task. Study psychology. Next, is
a learning task, study sociology. For retroactive interference, we would have
memory loss for the first task, studying psychology. An example of proactive
interference would be, first, studying psychology, then learning sociology.
With this, we would have memory loss for studying sociology because it came
second.